[Music]
micah is with us in atlanta hey Micah
how are you I'm doing well how are you
today better than I deserve what's up
hey I'm just calling I just found out
about Dave Ramsey and I wish I knew
about you four years ago I am starting
baby step one and I'm currently saving
and I was wondering how long of doing
the budget well I
why not feel constricted or will I not
feel like I don't have enough money at
the end of my two week pay period if
that makes sense well the budget you
decide what's in there you decide how
constricted you are if you're not
deciding then that tells me your incomes
too low and you're struggling so the
budgets not what causing you to feel
constricted the budget is just admitting
that you were constricted right but but
that's that's if your income is low but
if you make a bunch of money and your
self constricting in order to hit some
goals like paying off debt and doing
baby steps of one and two then that's a
self decision to feel constricted and as
long as you know you've got power over
that decision it limits how you've how
much you feel constricted but it's kind
of like you know when your little kids
your brother your cousin or somebody
says you're not the boss of me
you remember that and that's what the
budget is the budget isn't your you're
the boss of the budget until you get it
written down and then once you've
decided that then the budget becomes
your out-of-bounds marker it becomes the
boss of you but by the way it's your
budget so you decided how constricted
you were unless you don't have enough
income coming in and then that's going
to be there you generally will feel like
you've gotten a raise the first month
you do the budget but it's not going to
be real accurate you're gonna make
mistakes the first month it takes about
three months of doing it to get your
competency level up your the quality of
your budget goes up every month for the
first three months after 90 days you're
gonna be pretty good at it I mean you'll
be a bunch of nice to write or whatever
you call it right you'll be good
and jump on every dollar and get the app
it'll help you mic up it's free every
dollar app for your you know for your
iPhone or your Android and jump on there
and get that or just for your desktop
either one it's all free jump on there
and get that and that'll help you do the
budget quickly and easily and change it
if you need to change it then but the
constriction is up to you this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]